if you're alex smith
would you rather watch the team that
replaced you with colin kaepernick win
the super bowl or would you rather watch
the team that replaced you with patrick
mahomes win the super bowl oh that's a
good question good one stats i like that
i think i would rather see the one
that patrick mahomes being replaced i
feel like he was treated with a little
bit more respect and dignity with kansas
city right and and there's no one left
in stanford there's no one left there
exactly right he doesn't know this
regime or anything like that so uh i
would think that would be easier to
swallow and the fact that you're seeing
patrick mahomes and you just that's an
undeniable talent to where you could
swallow that a little bit more just go
hey that guy's better than me like i
understand i'm going with him yeah i
mean jim harbaugh did not hesitate to
supplant
alex smith with colin kaepernick right
concussion during the 2012 season
kaepernick inn and that was that was it
and there was no looking back the chiefs
gave alex smith all of the 2017 season
he embraced that role he helped teach
patrick holmes i think there's some
ownership of alex smith sure buy this
and let me tell you something i do not
put it past the chiefs to give alex
smith a super bowl oh i hear you if they
win
didn't the eagles do that with yeah
yeah long snapper who was no longer
there they did it will not surprise me
if alex smith gets a super bowl ring
from the chiefs if they win it all uh
you're right i wouldn't be surprised to
see that either andy reese that kind of
guy classy that way um yeah that would
be awesome and there'd be no reason for
the 49ers to give him one no reason no
no no no you're right there's there's
nothing it has nothing to do with this
team the time has been the gap has been
too big there's no there's no relevance
anymore all right if you're dan quinn
the falcons head coach would you rather
see your friend kyle shanahan win his
first super bowl or would you rather see
the offensive coordinator that blew a
28-3 lead
in your shot at the super bowl win
lose another super bowl same guy yes
different different context i think he'd
probably want to see him lose okay yeah
i do you know like i'm sure there's some
like hey you know professional respect
and all those things but
you know
i think kyle winning
takes a little if kyle wins it takes a
little luster off of what dan quinn's
done and really they've never been as
good since kyle left right so uh i think
a shanahan super bowl victory kind of uh
what do i want to say vindicates that he
was really one of the stronger things in
that organization at that time and was
the big reason they were in that super
bowl and even up 28 to three so i would
expect the i would take the lose one
there what do you think well i i'm gonna
i'm gonna apply a different twist too
yeah from the standpoint of trying to
convince the falcons that they can be
right back in this game as soon as next
year
i'd like to see the 49ers win it because
then dan quinn can say to his guys we
went there and beat them only three
teams beat them all year long we went to
santa clara and we beat them on their
own field in a game that they needed to
win
we need to be a good point mike that we
are good enough to be right back at the
top of the nfl
san francisco winning it right gives
that even more credibility
you're right it does that'll give a team
confidence in the offseason the core of
players that you bring back can sit
there and go listen we beat the super
bowl champs on their on their field
we're not that far off that's that's
valid all right next would you rather if
you're a super bowl mvp voter would you
rather vote for an undeserving player
from the winning team or vote for a
deserving candidate from the losing team
and this is an appropriate question
because i think at the finals win
there's a chance patrick mahomes will be
the mvp the first mvp from a losing
super bowl team since chuck howley in
super bowl five well yeah let's lay out
the scenario right because i know we
talked about this in our podcast in
front of people last night at the
playwright irish pub right like it would
have to be like a 4138 kind of game
right high scoring the 49ers stats are
spread out evenly right through guys
right where it's running back by
committee everybody does well there
george kittle has a good day garoppolo
has a good day but nobody blows us out
of the out of the you know out of the
room and then mahomes loses but throws
for 500 yards and five touchdowns and
makes all these magical plays yes that
would be it so you're asking me would i
rather if you if you're casting the
ballot is it more satisfying to to to to
say if it's close right you're picking a
guy whose numbers aren't great but he's
from the winning team would you rather
do that because you're going to go with
a winner or would you rather say here's
a guy who's had a better game than
anyone else on the field but his team's
going to lose but he's still the mvp see
i think a lot of the voters have enough
of a contrarian streak that they could
be
doing if the 49ers win but there isn't
one person who really stands out the way
mahomes will stand out vote for my homes
to be the mvp from the losing yeah i
think i would still rather vote for the
mvp of the winning team i do i think and
it would be tough you know especially
with the scenario we just tried to
explain and do all that i'll just say
one there was one super bowl that i was
that that i witnessed uh and this was
the toughest call i ever saw was the
super bowl 25 right the buffalo bills
versus the new york giants thurman
thomas had a phenomenal game he was the
best player on the field
but the giants pulled off an upset and
they pulled off the upset because of o.j
anderson and his ability maybe not to be
as sexy as thurman thomas but to pound
for four pound for five oh a hole breaks
open and here comes the uppercut into
you know what was that safety's name on
the buffalo bills he used to wear the
shell on his helmet cal mark kelsey let
it go peter king you the man that's why
he's peter king and but that to me he
was the mvp of that game because he
helped them win so it's a tough one but
i'd rather go with the the winning team
all right if you're mike holmes what
would you do you gotta answer stop doing
that tonight i i have enough of a
contrarian in me that i'm kind of
rooting for the 49ers win i want patrick
i
i like a lot of chaos shut up all right
if you're mike holmgren former head
coach of the packers yeah former head
coach of the seahawks long time
assistant with the 49ers right would you
rather see your old
employee andy reed finally win a super
bowl or see your old team the 49. this
one's easy winneston i want to read yeah
i mean 49ers have their trophies right
right randy reed deserves his if i'm
mike holmgren i want to see andy reid
get his fingerprints on the line
definitely the the personal you know
relationship there will be gratifying
for mike homer also professionally it's
just another guy under his tree that's
gone on to be really successful to where
he can you know toot his own horn to go
look hey i got another guy that won a
super bowl under my coaching tree so
yeah that one was the easy one it is an
amazing when you think of the 92 packers
what when you see that photo right like
john gruden and marion
steve mariucci i mean the list goes on
and on and it's crazy right now so many
guys who became nfl head coaches on that
staff in 1992 that was really the year
the packers
went down the process of re-establishing
them right right all right if you're the
commissioner of the nfl roger goodell
would you rather have a super bowl with
no controversy at all or would you
rather have an obvious past interference
call get
correctly reviewed and overturned oh
um i still think it would rather have no
controversy overall you know i mean the
the
the
interference thing and get it correctly
overturned would be a good look for what
we've gone through this year but i still
think that's gonna make people upset in
certain areas and again the interference
thing is one of those things where not
everybody's always going to agree on it
so i'd rather go i think he would rather
have no controversy even if it works
perfectly even if and i think the way
that i should have framed this is
there's a
an instance of past interference that
happens that isn't called on the field
but they use replay review to get it
right even if it works perfectly it's a
reminder of what a cluster it's been all
year yeah i want no reminders i don't
either of that let's just have a clean
game with no controversy no reminder of
one of the most awkward procedures the
nfl has put in place in decades yeah
let's get through to the end of the
season come up with another way to deal
with the worst case scenario that played
out in the ram saints nfc championship
game last year and move on i think
that's that's a no-brainer bye-bye see
you slug
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports